>> We'll get started.
So, this is the session
on Blockchains,
so welcome to this session
on Blockchains.
So, we have a bunch of interesting
talks in this session.
Our first presentation
will be on a work that
marries traditional
databases with Blockchain.
The second work would be
on exploring how we can
use computation verification
in the setting of Blockchain.
Then finally we have another work
that explores how we can use
enclaves to kind of achieve
better performance
and confidentiality
in the context of Blockchains.
So, the first speaker
is going to be
Professor Carsten Binnig from
Technical University
of Darmstadt.
He's also an adjunct professor at
Brown University and before
that he was an architect
at SAP HANA.
He's a recipient of
Google Faculty Award and he has
a bunch of Best Paper
Awards at IEEE,
Big Data and VLDB and
SIGMOD and he's been
recently exploring
the overlap between Blockchains
and databases and he's
going to talk about that.
>> Wonderful. Good.
Do you hear me?
So, the mic should be on.
So, today, as Arvind mentioned,
I'm talking about a database
view on Blockchains.
So, my main research is
actually, in general,
in distributed
databases, especially
distributed databases
together with networks.
So, I'm a database person.
Just to give you a quick
introduction where I come from.
So, why I got interested
in Blockchains is
because people are not using
Blockchains for
cryptocurrencies only,
but they use Blockchains
more and more
for general shared databases,
to write data into from
one trusted domain and
access it from
another trusted domain.
The main reason why
people are using it as
a platform for data sharing is,
there are many different reasons.
One is because it keeps
the history of all transactions.
Meaning, if something is
wrong in your database,
you can go back and still
look at what went wrong.
In some states in the USA,
they even changed the laws
that blockhains or
the data in Blockchain counts
as evidence in court,
which is a strong reason
if you share data
between different
trusted domains.
The second one is why
it's interesting is
also because no tampering
is possible after-the-fact.
So, once the transaction is in,
you cannot modify the list of
transactions you store
in your Blockchain.
Even more interesting, you
don't need a trusted authority
for making all these decisions.
So, the machinery and Blockchain
is designed in order to
give you the two properties,
that it stores all transactions
and it doesn't allow
tampering without having
a trusted authority.
So, and you see
that it's actually used as
shared databases and there are
many applications outside that
try actually to use
Blockchains already
as a shared database.
They range from different
or cover different domains,
not data, just in from
health institutions,
but also supply chains where
you have different entities,
the supplier and the manufacturer
requiring to access
the same database.
But also to other use
cases where you want to
have decentralized
copyright management.
So, for example, Binded is
a copyright management
platform for
images where you
put in the image,
it gets a timestamp and
thus it has the copyright,
and if somebody else at the end
wants to upload
another similar image,
you have to prove
that the other image
was in the database before.
So, the question is
now, are we done now?
Is this the end of the talk?
So, are existing
Blockchain systems,
is they are good
enough for supporting
all the different applications
that people have in
mind and when they want to use
them as a shared database?
So, what I'm going to do
in the talk is, therefore,
I'm first going quickly- I think
most of the people might
know the Blockchain basics,
but I'll still go quickly over
the Blockchain background,
some basic terms that I'm not
talking about things that are
out of context in
the rest of the talk,
then talk about the challenges
why Blockchains, in my eyes,
are not sufficient
yet to use them as
a shared database and
then go towards what
we've been doing in the past year
with Blockchain to be developing
a shared or Database
System on top of
Blockchains that mitigate some
of the problems that we've seen,
or that I am going
to discuss before.
So, for Blockchains,
just the quick overview,
I don't want to
spend too much time.
So, Blockchains
the basis they use,
a tamper-proof ledger
to store data,
which I already
mentioned, it's a list of
transactions, it's append only.
The transactions are
appended in blocks,
so if new data is written,
the new data is appended or mined
in blocks and the ledger
is fully replicated.
Here you see already,
if something is mined or
appended in blocks and
it's fully replicated,
there seems to be a lot
of inefficiency in
the system itself and this is,
again, one of the challenges
that you tackle when you
want to use it as a
general-purpose Database System.
So, why it's so interesting
as a shared database,
I already mentioned is, if
an update happened to
the shared database,
which is replicated to
all the peers in the Blockchain,
then everybody or
at least the majority
depending on what protocol you're
using is to agree on
the appends and there are
different ways to assure that,
nevermind what you
are using, if you're
using a public
or private Blockchain.
That's what also we will
go over in a few seconds.
The last bit of piece
of information that
I'd like to introduce is
the term smart contracts,
which are nothing else
than trusted procedures
that are stored in the
Blockchain that can modify data.
It's your custom logic that
you deploy in a Blockchain.
For database person, it
would be something like
a stored procedure that can
be called from outside.
But for smart contracts,
the specific thing is
that all the participants
agree on the same code if
you're on the Blockchain.
The second slide, just to
get the background right,
there are two platforms
or ways how Blockchains
are deployed.
There are public Blockchains,
means that everybody,
every participant,
can join the Blockchain and
they usually use more expensive
consensus protocols.
I won't go into
details for those,
but just to make sure that
we're on the same side,
there are also
private Blockchains,
which target a different type
of application where not
everybody is allowed to
join the Blockchain but
it's more limited set,
targeted towards a limited set of
participants that
know each other.
Therefore, they use a bit of
less expensive consensus
protocols and this
already increases
the performance a bit when
you use Blockchains
as a Database System.
So, the question is,
that's where I'd actually
like to start my talk,
what are the challenges
if you want to use
a Blockchains as
a shared Database System?
The main challenge, I
already mentioned that,
is clearly the performance
of Blockchains.
There was a paper last year
on SIGMOD where they analyzed
the throughput and the latency
of different Blockchain systems.
One is Ethereum, that
is pretty well-known,
which you can set up as
a public but also as
a private Blockchain,
as well as Hyperledger,
which is the IBM version
of Blockchain system.
But what you see here is
that the throughput, for example,
for a classical
database benchmarks,
so if you use the Blockchains as
a key-value store,
it's pretty low.
So, they reported
around, for Ethereum,
around 300 transactions per
second that can be executed.
If you look carefully
in the paper,
this is not the average
transaction rate,
that's the peak transaction rate.
So, the average transaction rate
is actually much, much lower.
So, clearly here you see that
the transaction and
the performance that you get,
the transaction rate,
the throughput
and the latency
that you get out of
these Blockchains is far from
what typical
applications need today.
Even, for example, if you look at
what Visa is
processing on average,
so Visa transactions are
around 2,000
transactions per second.
If you look into the applications
how people want to
use Blockchains,
they also want to store
sensor data in the Blockchain,
which even require much higher
transaction rates.
So, the performance
itself is one problem.
The second one is, if you today
want to use one of
the Blockchain systems
to set up a shared database,
you are confronted with the
"zoo" of those systems,
and it's really not
clear which one to use.
They come, (a) with
different programming
and execution models,
and the question is with
which platform are you able
to implement your logic
that you want to have
for the shared database.
Where can you implement? In which
can you implement transactions or
the transaction logic that
is needed for use case.
Even worse, because there's
so much development going on,
you don't know what is
the best Blockchain
for your workload and
(b) which ones will
survive at the end,
because there's
so much movement in the sector
and people are trying to
come up with optimizations,
new platforms and it's unclear
which one you should
build your shared
database application on.
The last one is even more
severe, that Blockchains,
you might assume if you deploy
your code in the
Blockchain and run it,
you get some kind- because
even procedures run through
the consensus mechanism that
multiple nodes need to execute
the same code bases
and at the end
the output of
the procedure is verified,
so meaning if
all the outputs are equal.
But that's not true
for purely read
only functions that you would
implement in your smart contract.
They are only executed by
one peer in the Blockchain.
Meaning, if that one peer,
if that one node,
is malicious and you
are asking or you're
sending a read request
to that one peer,
you might get a wrong value
from the peer end.
So, the guarantees we are
getting for reads, for example,
is not enough for
many of the shared database
where you want to know,
is the value I've
been reading actually
the value that is
stored in the database?
So, there are
many guarantees that you
actually then want to add to
your Database System or to your,
if you use your Blockchain
as a shared database,
and what we think would be
nice is if you could
execute transactions on
a shared Blockchain,
at the end verify if the
execution of the transaction,
meaning if all your read and
write operations
was correct with
regard to the guarantees what
the database wants to give you,
and if you discover that
a violation happened,
that you can go back to
the last verified checkpoint.
So, the ideas of
transactional theory more
into implemented in Blockchains,
but also transactions
that are verifiable.
So, how are we going
to achieve this?
This is the idea of BlockchainDB.
The idea is that we built
a Middleware on top
of Blockchains.
The idea is what
the BlockchainDB gives
us is that it gives
us a unified API.
So, we tackle the problem
of having a sue of those systems
by having a unified front-end
and an exchangeable back-end,
similar to what MySQL is today.
For databases, you get
a unified front-end and you
can plug in your storage
engine that you like to have,
which gives you the
performance characteristics
maybe that you want to
have for your application.
The second one is
that we can apply
typical database optimizations
in the Middleware.
So, we've seen that
the performance itself
is a major limitation,
and by applying some tricks
in the Middleware,
by sharding across
certain Blockchains,
we can achieve much higher
throughput than
what the existing Blockchains
give us already.
The last one is that
we want to support
this notion of
verifiable transactions.
So, executing read/write
operations via the BlockchainDB,
and then at the end getting a
verification mechanism
that tells us
is a transaction that we've
executed been correct with
regard to the consistency level,
for example, selected
in the Database System?
Now you could argue,
"Okay, a BlockchainDB,
this is the component that runs
outside of your Blockchain.
So, it's an untrusted component,
doesn't it make things harder?"
I'll come to that at the end
and I'll talk a bit about how
we deal with verification
with a new component that
is actually untrusted.
So, what we've
actually been building
in the last year is not
a full Database System,
but as a first step,
we started to build
a Middleware that has
a simple put/get interface
because this is already from,
as a basic building block,
we think we can use later on to
build transactions on top, and b,
it gives us already proof of
concept of how far can we get
with transaction rates
if you have
just a simple put/get workload.
So, the idea is we have
a Blockchain key-value
store that supports
at the beginning only the simple
put/get operations
that we have here and
we have pluggable back-ends.
Inside the Blockchain,
in order to achieve
the higher performance and
implement some database
optimizations,
we selected a bunch of techniques
that are implemented
in the Middleware,
be it from sharding,
the data into
multiple Blockchains,
so not using just one.
This is a thing that already
some of the Blockchains
do by now inside the
Blockchain system,
they support sharding but
not all of the systems
support it.
So, what we can do is just
put that on top and support,
that way some
data-parallel execution
across Blockchains because if you
look a bit deeper into
the execution models of
Blockchains they are to
be fully serialized,
a serialized execution with
no parallel execution
of transactions at all,
and the sharding gives us
some way of parallelizing.
We implemented a bunch
of other optimizations.
I want to go just in two of
them and show you quickly
what the performance and
impacts are if you
do that or if you implement
those in the Middleware.
The first one is, so
the question is if you
provide a put/get interface,
what consistency can be provided
if you use a Blockchain?
In Blockchain key-value store,
we support different notions
of consistency levels
or clients like
consistency levels
that are more expensive
or less expensive.
The idea is that if
you give up some of
the consistency similar to
what normal databases also do,
you can get higher
performance even
when we use a Blockchain
as a back-end.
The idea here is that if you
use a higher consistency
level, for example,
read your own writes, what
we do in the Middleware
if a write is coming in,
if a put is coming in,
it's first submitted to
the Blockchain but we
don't wait for the transaction
actually committed,
but only that it's validated.
After that, we just append it to
a list in our Middleware,
meaning that once a read is
coming in for the same key,
at that moment we do lazy
blocking on the
pending transaction
and wait for
the transaction to be
pre-committed before we
give back the value.
So, this is one
technique where you
already don't need to wait
for the full execution
of a transaction,
but you still get
a guaranteed consistency level
which many of the
applications desire.
Or you can even go
lower and provide
only eventual consistency and
even don't wait for
the transaction
to be committed and execute,
just read operations completely
on the status you are
getting and monitor if
these transactions
are finally commit,
so if you can still
guarantee liveliness.
What you see here is
that if you implement
just on using a 50/50
workloads of 50 reads,
50 percent writes, and
Ethereum as a back-end.
If you want to provide read
your own writes semantics,
you get only throughput of
20 put/get operations
at a second,
and this is in line with
a block bench numbers.
If you look a bit closer,
they reported
only numbers as I said
for max throughput and not
for average throughput.
See, the eventual consistency
gives you already a boost
of a factor of five in
terms of transactions
which is not
still there what many of
the application needs,
but it's already a way of
getting higher performance
out of your Blockchain system if
you decrease
the consistency level.
A second technique that
actually is helping
much more is that,
in our Middleware we implemented
some form of batching.
So, we don't submit puts one by
one to the Blockchain
because the pair
of transaction overhead
of validating
transactions is pretty high.
So meaning, if you
batch them together,
so multiple puts
in one Blockchain
transaction, you can get,
for example, if you block
up to 500 puts in one call,
the transaction rate of 1,200
transactions per second.
After that, the
maximum message size
we used here four byte
integers is exceeded,
so that's the limit of
batching that you can use.
So, the plain database
tricks is one thing,
but the question is now,
I mentioned a third point
which is important,
that is getting verifiability
of your operations.
This is something that we also
implemented inside Blockchain
or inside our system.
The idea of verifiable
consistency is that
a client can verify the
correctness of all operations,
meaning if the puts
and gets that he
executed that he sees
or that he executed
adhere to the selected
consistency level.
So, what does it mean for
eventual consistency?
It means for the
eventual consistency
that the client doesn't
see any fake reads.
So, if you think about a
scenario where, for example,
the Blockchain
Middleware or one of
the peers is malicious,
he might return
just the value that
is not stored in your database
and we want to be able to
detect it after the fact.
If you use a Blockchain system
out of the box,
you don't get that guarantee.
The second one is
that we want to,
for example, our
eventual consistency,
we will also want to
support life in there.
So, we want to assure that
all the puts that
I executed through
BlockchainDB are actually stored
in the Blockchain system and not
dropped again by one
of the components.
So, the problem is
that as I mentioned,
that all these operations or
these guarantees could
be violated because,
in our setup, we have
multiple untrusted components.
One is our Blockchain
key value store
that we introduced
as a Middleware.
But there's also
the peers themselves,
if you look at them individually,
they are untrusted.
Meaning, if you just go
to one of the peers,
we might get the problem
of fake reads,
and reads are actually
executed by only one peer.
So, it's a problem of detecting
if you get a fake read or if,
for example, the
Blockchain Middleware or
the peer drops a transaction
and doesn't execute it.
How we do it is so here
just a high-level overview is
the idea is that we use
deferred verification mechanism
where every put that
is executed through
the key value store updates
the write set in the
Blockchain itself,
and the clients additionally
lock their actions,
their reads and writes
set, they don't need to
do it for each individual call.
But they lock the read
and write set
not using the Middleware layer,
but bypassing the Middleware.
They lock the reads and writes
sets into the Blockchain as well.
The nice point about
these calls is they don't
need to be synchronous blocking,
you can just send
them asynchronously.
At the end of your Epoch when
you execute it multiple
of the puts and gets,
what you want to do is also
a verification procedure that
looks into the question
if the write set was
included that
the clients reported via
their record calls is included in
the write set that the key
value store was seen.
This is also again a
non-blocking operation means we
submit that as
a Blockchain transactions,
so implemented as
a store procedure as
a smart contract which checks
if these two guarantees
are satisfied.
Once it's done, we can just fetch
the result if the
Epoch was correct,
if all the operations
have been correct.
In worst case, rollback
in the transaction
history to a point
where the last verified Epoch
was stored in the database.
So, we can also recover
to valid checkpoints.
Good. So there's much more,
many more details that
you need to think
about if you want to do
verification with
Blockchain and there are
more details I haven't been
including in the slides,
but this is the general notion
of how we want to
ensure that puts and gets
are executed correctly.
So what are we up to next?
So, as I said,
it's a first step
that we implemented.
There are many more optimizations
that we haven't implemented.
For example, caching
in the Middleware
but still guaranteeing
verifiability.
That's something we are
working on at the moment.
Then for sure go in
the route of having
not just the put/get
interface but supporting
full database transactions on
top of our key value
store interface.
So, in long-term,
what we want to achieve
or how we think
that our Middleware could be
integrated into a data
management stack is also have
a combination of a database
that is running on-premise,
where you use the
Blockchain Database System
to integrate something like
a Shared column into
your local Database system.
Meaning, you create a table,
just mark your column
as "Shared",
and by getting the guarantees of
verifiable transactions
and sharing on
those columns of data
is automatically
written to the Blockchain,
and you can verify
for those columns
if transactions on
those columns have been right.
But this is something we haven't
started thinking about in detail.
With that, I'm at
the end of the talk,
happy to take questions.
I'm sure we have time for
questions at all. Yeah.
>> So, you cited
a sigma paper saying that
even if you set up a
private environment
around Blockchain,
the throughput is
very limited, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, intuitively
I have hard time to
understand why this case and I
wonder if you can
share some insight.
>> You mean why the transaction
rate of Blockchains.
So, I haven't been going
into the details of the
execution models of Blockchains.
But for example,
public Blockchain use
a consensus protocol which
is called "Proof of Work".
Meaning, that one
was private, yeah.
For them, as I said so,
the complete transact
for private Blockchains,
the problem is
that, the execution
of all transactions
is fully serialized.
Meaning one node takes a set
of transactions, executes them,
distributes the results to
all the peers in
the Blockchain and
they re-execute
the transactions to
verify the outcome
of the transactions.
Then, if different peers
agrees or different peers or
the majority agrees,
the block is appended.
Which is inherently,
so full replicated Database
System that doesn't allow
any concurrency and
the results that you
are seeing is and there are
many more overheads
in Blockchains,
which is not just
the execution but
also verifying
the signatures for each and
every transactions, etcetera.
Yeah. Mike.
>> I'm just curious if
you could give us a feel.
I know you didn't go
into the details of
Blockchain Protocols
but is there something
fundamentally
different with using
Blockchain as the backend for
the key value store
as opposed to if
you were just
building a Federated
Database over a bunch of
slow Database Systems
where you would
be faced with a lot of
the same challenges?
>> There are two answers from
my side to your question.
The first one is,
why don't you use
a Database System or
replicate the Database System
from the start for
those use cases.
But that's a valid question.
So, the answer is, for me,
people are using
Blockchains nowadays and it
has this legal notion that
data that is stored in
a Blockchain can be used
as evidence for court.
So, there are already
some mechanisms in place that
you don't have a database.
There are reasons why people
should use a Blockchain.
For some use cases,
it's not possible to start with
a Database System as
a starting point.
The second one is,
regarding the performance,
I think that we saw already
from the talk from
Microsoft in the morning,
there's a lot going on
in optimizing the performance
of Blockchain Systems themselves.
We just benefit from it.
Whatever comes next
as a platform,
we can plug it in as a backend
and use it and provide
a verification guarantees on top.
This is what, let's say
the value of what we provide is.
So, you get the interface
of a typical Database,
you can verify your transaction.
So put get operations as if
it would be a Database but at
the end, it's a Blockchain.
So, we provide a stable interface
you can program against it from
your application and get
the advantages from
your Blockchain Systems.
>> Assume we moved from
'Proof of Work" to "Proof of
Stake" and assume every block
can pack tens of transactions.
Where would you imagine would
be the next bottleneck,
in terms of improving
the performance of Blockchain
transaction processing?
>> We haven't been ourselves
not looking too much
into where the bottlenecks
of current systems are.
There two good papers
that analyze actually
the performance
bottlenecks and where
are the limits of
how far could we
push the performance if
we tweak the parameters.
There's one from a bunch of
authors from ETH, Cornell,
et cetera, where they
theoretically
analyzed where is the
upper bound with
the current protocols.
I think that's a nice read.
Anyway, the second
one is Blockbench,
where we're running
already against
different systems with
different consensus
protocol workloads.
From my perspective, what
I think Blockchain should do is,
the computational
or the execution
of transactions is
inherently inefficient.
As I said, it's completely
sequentialized.
There's no notion of concurrency,
and I think Blockchains
can learn a lot from what
databases have been
doing in concurrency.
So, executing transactions as
if they would be serialized.
See, if they would be serial but
having actually a concurrent
execution and if you
can get some ideas of those into
the next generation of
Blockchain Systems,
it would increase the performance
and reduce the bottleneck
of what current Blockchains have.
>> All right.
I think we are running
slightly behind scheduled.
If you have further questions,
we might want to
do a short break.
So, we'll thank the speaker. Yes.
>> Thanks.
>> So, the next speaker in
this session is Srinath.
So, Srinath as a researcher
at Microsoft Research
at Redmond labs and
Srinath is an expert
on having periodic systems
around verifying of computation,
around computation verification.
In this talk, he's going to talk
about a system called Spice,
which is about
verifiable state machine
and this work is going to
appear at OSDA this year.
>> Can you hear me?
Think it's working.
Okay, thanks.
So this talk is about
the powerful primitive card
Verifiable state machines.
The system that implements this
primitive is called Spice.
This primitive as
many applications
in the context stuff for
trustworthy Cloud Services as
well as de-centralized
Blockchains.
I'll start by defining
what this primitive is.
A Verfiiable state machine is a
primitive in which there are
three types of entities;
a set of clients,
a statefull service,
and a set of verifiers.
These clients issue
a st of request to
the service and get back
a set of responses.
Then the service
periodically publishes
a trace which contains
an entry for each request
response pair.
Then each of these verifiers
run instead set of
local checks and then
output, accept or reject.
Then we call such a primitive as
a Verifiable state machine if
it satisfies these properties.
First, if the service behaves,
that is the execution
is equivalent to
some serial execution of
the concurrent requests,
then the verifier
is output accept.
Second, if the service
misbehaves with
execution of a request or
with concurrency
control mechanisms,
then the probability that
a verifier outputs accept
should be less than epsilon,
where epsilon is very small.
Third, the trace itself
is zero knowledge,
that is it does not
reveal anything about
the requests or the responses
or the internal
state of the service
beyond the validity of
the correct request execution.
Finally, we require each entry
in this trace to be small,
for example, a few 100 bytes.
It turns out, there's
a lot of prior work that
implicitly implements
this Verifiable State
machine abstraction.
They do not use the state
machine formalism
but it's not fundamental.
The theory actually dates
back to early 90's.
But this theory was too
expensive to be implemented.
How does a lot of
work that reduces
the cost of this theory by
all 20 orders of magnitude?
These latter systems, supplied
support for stateful computations
in those earlier systems.
For example, they support
storage interfaces such as
key-value stores and
even a limited form
of SQL Databases.
Despite this massive progress,
all of these systems have
two key limitations.
First, the storage operations
in these systems
are very expensive.
For example, it would
take tens of seconds or
even several minutes for
each storage operation.
Second limitation is
that they only support
a sequential model of
execution for expressing
these services.
As a result of
these two limitations,
prior work can only support
very limited throughput even
for very simple services.
Our system, which is called
Spice addresses
these limitations.
First, it features a new
storage primitive that is
two orders of magnitude more
efficient than
prior instantiations.
Second, it supports
a concurrent model of
execution for
expressing services.
As a result of these two
new techniques,
Spice can support thousands
of transactions per
second for many realistic
applications.
In the rest of
this talk, I'm going
to focus on three things.
First, I'll discuss
a few applications that
can be built with
verifiable state machines.
Second, I'll present
some background on
prior work and
a quick overview of Spice.
Finally, I'll present
some experimental results.
At a very high level,
we are interested in
this primitive verifiable state
machines for two reasons.
First, it enables us to
build cloud services in
which we do not have to trust
the Cloud infrastructure.
Second, it also enables private
and efficient Blockchains
both in the permission
membership model
and permission-less
membership model.
I'll start with the first
application scenario.
The first application is
a Cloud-hosted ledger
inspired by Sequence.
Here, the service maintains
balances of assets owned
by different clients.
It exposes three types
of requests.
First, the Issue operation
enables an issuer which is
a special entity in the system
to issue some assets to a client.
The second operation is
a Transfer that allows
one client to transfer an asset
to a different client.
Finally, the last operation
which is called
Retire allows a client to
take an asset out of the system.
So in the status quo,
if somebody wants to
verify the correct execution
of this service,
they have to get a complete
trace of all the requests,
responses, and the internal
state of the service.
An auditor can verify
the correct execution
of the service
without access to any of the
requests or the responses.
It does not have to trust
the infrastructure on which
the services is running.
The second application
is in the context of
four decentralized
Blockchain such as Ethereum.
On Ethereum, a smart contract is
essentially a state machine
where two or more counter-parties
can issue transactions to
create state transitions.
So in the status quo,
all the transactions are
actually stored on
the Blockchain.
So this provides
no confidentiality guarantees.
Anyone in the world can
inspect the internal state of
the contract or also look at
all the state transitions
a contract has gone through.
Second, every request from
the app must be processed
by the Blockchain.
So this limits the
application level throughput
that you can get by storing
a smart contract on
a public Blockchain.
But as with verifiable
state machine,
you don't actually
have to execute
those smart contracts
on the Blockchain.
You can execute them outside
the Blockchain and then
process only a succinct
zero-knowledge trace
on the Blockchain.
Because this succinct trace
does not reveal anything
about the internal state
of the requests or the responses,
it provides very strong
confidentiality guarantees.
Because Ethereum will only
process a succinct trace,
you can actually support
very high throughput for
your applications which is
independent of the throughput
supported by Ethereum.
So I hope that I convinced you
that verifiable state
machines are actually useful.
So in the next part of this talk,
I'm going to provide some
background on a prior system
called Pantry before I
provide an overview of Spice.
So, Pantry itself extends
to prior systems called
Zaatar and Pinocchio to
support a notion of state.
All these three systems
are composed
of a front-end and a back-end.
This front-end
translates a C program
into a set of
algebraic constraints.
Then the back-end implements
an argument protocol to prove
the correct execution
of the C program.
I'm not going to go
into the details of
how these components work,
but I'll just observe that
both Zaatar and Pinocchio support
a large subset of C. This,
in turn, enables verifying
the execution of
stateless programs.
Then Pantry supports
state while working in
the same stateless
computation model
by leveraging
cryptographic hashes.
I'm going to briefly tell
you how this is done.
So the key idea in Pantry
is to name data blocks
using a short cryptographic
digest of those data blocks.
Here's a very small
C program that
illustrates the key
idea in Pantry.
It takes as input
a digest and then
the prover of the service
can actually supply state.
Of course, because
the service is entrusted,
it can support a supply
any state to this program.
But there is an assert
statement that checks if
the digest supplied
by the Verifier
equals the cryptographic hash
of the block supplied
by the service.
If the service supplies
the correct state,
just check passes;
otherwise, this check fails.
By using this idea,
Pantry builds a key-value store.
The core idea is to treat
hashes of data as
pointers to such data.
Then you can build
a tree and which in
turn can be used to
build a key value store.
But the fundamental problem in
this approach is that cost of
a key-value store operation is
logarithmic in
the size of the state.
Completely, this means it
takes several minutes of CPU time
even with the million
key-value pairs in your state.
Spice addresses
these performance problems.
The core idea in Spice is we use
a set data structure instead
of a tree data structure.
We then map key-value
store operations
to operations on a set.
As a result, the cost of
a storage operation is
constant time instead of
logarithmic on
an amortized basis.
However, if we instantiate
this idea naively,
it's actually going to be more
expensive than
the tree-based approach,
constraints involved
and in the case
of many data sizes that
we are interested in.
However, Spice
solves this problem.
It does this by using
an efficient instantiation of
the set-based data structure
using elliptic
curve cryptography.
Spice also includes
new techniques to execute
these state transitions or
transactions inexpensively
in this model.
I'm not going to go
into the details
of how all of this is done,
but I'll just present
a few implementation details
and how the system looks.
We implement Spice
on top of Pantry.
We also wrote three
applications using Spice,
but Spice includes
a toolchain using,
but you can build
many more applications.
The toolchain takes as input
a C program which expresses
a request handler and then
it outputs two executables,
one for the service and
one for the verifier.
This request handler can include
arbitrary C or can also call
into Spice's storage APIs.
The storage primitive
itself exposes many APIs.
First it provides you operations
and key-value stores
such as get and put.
Second, it allows
mutual exclusion
of APIs such as lock and unlock,
so you can lock a key, perform
an update, and then unlock.
It also provides a restricted
form of transactions.
So, you can call begin
transactions on a set of keys,
it returns the current state
of those keys.
Then you can do arbitrary
computation and then you can
call end transactions with
the values that you
want to write back.
All of this update
happens atomically.
In the next part of this talk,
I'm going to present
some experimental results.
There are two questions
that I'm interested in.
First, how does Spice
compare with prior
state-of-the-art?
Second, what is the
end-to-end performance
of applications built with Spice?
To answer these questions,
we run a set of
experiments on Azure Cluster.
So for the first question,
we measure the throughput of
key-value store operations under
Spice as well as a set
of baseline systems.
We preload the
key-value store with
a million key-value
pairs and then
we measure the throughput of
the system for get
input operations separately.
As against C, due to
new techniques in Spice,
Spice can achieve
up to four orders of
magnitude speed up compared
to the baseline systems.
So to answer the second question,
we implemented three
applications and this graph
depicts end-to-end
performance with
varying number of CPU cores.
In the x-axis, you
can see we have
depicted various requests
types such as issue,
transfer and retire,
that are supported by
these applications.
As we can see, Spice achieves
a near linear speedup
and throughput as we
provide more CPU cores.
I did not depict
the verifier's throughput,
but it's much more than
the prover's throughput of
the services throughput which
is 15 million proof verifications
per second on the same cluster.
So to summarize this talk,
we believe verifiable state
machines is a key tool in
the context of
both Cloud computing
and decentralized Blockchains.
Spice represents
a substantial progress towards
efficiently implementing
verifiable state machines.
Finally, we are excited about
the many possibilities
that this work points to.
With that, I can take questions.
Someone has a question.
I'm sorry, I kind of lost
the connection between
spice and the Blockchain.
So, where exactly,
are you using spices'
technology to implement
Blockchains or is
it a front end to
Blockchains because you're
using a code generator?
So, I don't know exactly
where the connection is.
>> There are two applications
that I guess I can go back.
Here is scenario that I presented
in the context of Blockchain.
So history of running
the entire smart contract
on the Blockchain,
and that executing the contract
on every node in
the Blockchain system,
you could run it once and
then you could just process
that succinct zero knowledge
trace on the Blockchain.
So, the entire Blockchain
network would just
verify that there was
a valid state transition,
and it does not
have to re-execute
any transactions and
they also don't need to
know what the contract
was or what this
contract was doing.
So it provides confidentiality
and also scalability.
>> So, you are basing like
a front end to the Blockchain?
>> Yes.
>> So, you don't need to use
a Blockchain in the back and
you could put in a database.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> If I did it, the Blockchain
is actually not relevant.
>> Yes. So, here,
only the verifier is
running the Blockchain but
you could run
that verifier anywhere.
>> Right.
>> Even the service itself
could be running outside
the Blockchain using
traditional databases.
>> All right. Okay. Thank you.
>> The trace includes all the
hashes of the state. Yes.
>> Can you return to the slide
that gave the big picture of
requests going into
the Blockchain and
the trace going to the verifies?
>> Is it this slide?
>> Yes. Could you say
what information the verifiers
have access to in order
to make the decision?
This picture depicts only
an append-only trace.
Are they aware of
other information?
>> Yes, they do know the
specification of the service.
For example, what means for
taking a state transition,
so they know the code that
represents the state transition.
They also know some encoding
of the requests and
the encoding of the responses.
So, this trace has an entry
for each request response pair.
>> So the verifiers are
aware of something
about the requests.
>> They don't know
the actual plaintext contents
of the request,
but they have
a succinct encoding which
is a commitment to
those requests.
>> Thanks.
>> Quick question while
we're on this slide.
So, you defined soundness
in terms of some epsilon.
So what should I think
of epsilon as being
like the Internet is very large,
and there are many requests?
>> Yes.
>> So, how often in
practice would you
expect soundness to be violated??
>> Yeah. So, this epsilon
is one and two power 128,
so you can think of it
as 128 bit security.
So, it should be very small
like you should absolutely
not see verified accepting
some incorrect
statement as correct,
except with that one
and two power 128,
which is the security of
many crypto primitives that
we use.
Thank you.
>> So, the final presentation in
the session is by Professor,
Dawn Song from UC Berkeley.
So, she has a whole
bunch of works.
So she is a MacArthur fellow,
she's associates at
Guggenheim fellow
and MIT TR-35 award,
and she has like
several best papers in
security and learning
conferences,
and she also happens to
be the co-founder of
a startup in Blockchain
called Oasis labs,
and I believe that some
of the work she'll be
talking about is based on,
is related to the startup also.
>> Okay. Great. Hello.
Hi everyone. So,
the mic is working.
Okay. Great. Thanks
a lot for being here,
I am Dawn Song,
I am a professor in
computer science at UC Berkeley,
and also I'm a founder
and CEO of Oasis Labs.
Today, I'll talk about
privacy preserving
smart contracts as
scale and new Blockchain
platform, that we're building.
Okay. So, right.
I know data is the new oil,
and all this data can really help
us with the value of data
analytics and machine learning,
and help us get insights
in many different domains
including healthcare,
financial services and IoT.
A lot of data is also
sensitive and and we
actually and facing allows us big
problems in
the data domain today.
For example, data breaches at
the common place now,
for example Equifax,
one of the largest
credit card companies
had the recent data
breaches where
attackers were able to steal
sensitive information about
more than 140 million users.
On the other hand, a lot
of valuable data is also
being siloed because
it is sensitive.
They could really be utilized,
and hence a lot of data
were not able to extract
valuable insights from
all this data including for
example medical data and
financial data and so on.
Also, at the same time,
users are losing control
of their data as
demonstrated in the recent
Cambridge Analytica incident.
So, on the other hand,
we are seeing that
Blockchain is providing
a transformative technology and
aiming to solve
a number of problems.
Blockchains aims to provide
openness and transparency,
and allow us to not to
rely on anything to party,
and provides automatic
enforcement of agreements.
So, so far, what has
Blockchains brought us?
It helps with payments,
with ICOs and cryptokitties.
So, the question is
in the future we hope that
Blockchain can do
even greater things,
can help us to revolutionize
many different segments in
industry including
financial services,
healthcare, IoT and
many other domains.
So, today I wanted to talk about
some new technology that we
have been developing that
actually helps bringing
the Blockchain technology to
a broader domain to enable
these other more
advanced applications
than the ones that
we have seen today,
and also at the same time
help solve some of
these data security
and privacy problems
that I just mentioned
at the beginning.
So, first, let me give
you one motivating
example how in such example,
how Blockchain help
solve the problem and
also where we need the new
technologies in Blockchain.
So, this motivating example is
in the area of fraud detection.
So for example, for banks,
they need to do
fraud detection to
figure out whether they
should give someone
along or with that suspicious
and malicious activities.
So, typically, high
works is that each bank
using its information can
change its own fraud detector,
and because the data is
sensitive and usually
it is difficult to
find different banks to
collaborate together.
However, as we all know,
the effectiveness of
these tab of models,
and it really depends on
the amount of data that
the model is trained on or
the broad views that
the model actually had seen.
Hence, it would have been
really nice if we can
develop a technology that
allows these different banks
to collaborate together,
and using the data from
each of the banks together
to develop a better machinery
model for fraud detector.
Unfortunately, today, we don't
have a technology to enable
the banks to do this because
of privacy concerns,
regulatory risks, and
the misaligned incentives.
>> So, this is an example where
actually Blockchain can
help and in particular,
a new type of
a Blockchain technology
such as the ones that
we're developing can help.
We can actually develop
smart contract,
in this case, a fraud
detector smart contract,
that runs on top
of the Blockchain.
In this case,
the different banks,
and each of them can
actually contribute
data to this smart contracts,
and that together using
the data from
these different sources,
the fraud detector
smart contract can
change fraud detection model.
Hopefully, this
fraud detection model that
change using data from
different banks can
be much more effective
and can really help
each bank to deal with
the fraud much better.
However, in order to enable
an application like this,
we need to solve a number
of challenges and issues.
So, first, in
a typical Blockchain,
actually, our data in
compute on the
Blockchain is public.
In this case, we are dealing with
very sensitive data, essentially
customers' transactions.
So, we need to handle
the challenge of
having sensitive data on
the Blockchain worker notes,
essentially protecting
the computation process of
this much contract execution
from leaking
sensitive information.
Secondly, the computer
fraud detection model
itself can potentially leak
sensitive information about
the inputs because the
machine in the model
here that is changed from
sensitive inputs to start with,
and I'll show a little bit later
that our work has shown
that even when you
turn machinery model,
I feel I'm now careful with
the privacy protection than
this two-dimensional boundary
itself can actually
leak sensitive information
about the inputs.
Finally, to this Blockchain has
a huge scalability issues and to
this Blockchain has poor
performance and very high costs.
So again, in order to enable
an application like this,
we really need to be able to
scale up the Blockchain and
scalability to enable a real-world
applications like this,
and ideally at
the class scale event.
>> Question. What about
the smart contract that
the fraud detection model?
Isn't that private?
Isn't that important too?
>> So, that's why I
will talk about this.
Yes. So, we're actually
going to develop
a privacy preserving
smart contracts
that can help save others.
So, in order to enable
application like this
and address the challenges
that I just mentioned,
an Oasis where developing
a new Blockchain technology
called privacy,
one of the key about
Blockchain platform
is Privacy-preserving
Smart Contracts at Scale.
So first, one of the key
primitive of our platform is
a Privacy-preserving
Smart Contracts.
The premise of Privacy-preserving
Smart Contracts
satisfies a number of unique
properties and capabilities.
It enables automatic enforcement
of codified privacy requirements.
So, the privacy requirements here
as coded into
the smart contracts.
We can enforce this
without relying on
any central party
and it's designed to
scale to real-world applications
including heavy workloads
such as machine learning.
We design the technology to make
it easy to use and
to make it much
easier for Developers to build
the privacy-preserving
applications without
needing to be a privacy experts.
In order to enable
this Privacy-preserving
Smart Contract at Scale,
we developed a number of
different technologies
and combined
together to build
our Oasis Blockchain platform.
The Oasis Blockchain platform
essentially has,
you can do to it's
two main parts,
there's the platform
component and there is
the application components
where the smart contracts is
the abstraction at
the application level.
So, at the platform
level, so first, we build
confidentiality-preserving
smart contract execution to
protect the smart contract
execution process
from leaking sensitive
information about the inputs.
At the application level
within the smart contract,
we provide capabilities for
privacy-preserving analytics
and machine learning to make it
easy for Developers
to do analytics and
machine learning without
needing to worry about privacy,
and to enforce the desire
to privacy policies.
At the platform level,
we also developed
a new architecture
for the Blockchain to enable
scalable smart contract
execution in particular
for scalability for complex
smart contract execution.
So, now, let me talk about
each component
technology separately.
So, first, let me talk about
the confidentiality-preserving
smart contract execution.
So typically, again,
as I mentioned,
so most Blockchain today,
they data and compute our
public on the Blockchain,
hence they can only have
very limited used cases.
So, in this case,
the inputs to the smart
contracts is public,
and the smart contracts
essentially then
takes the inputs,
and does a computation,
and performs a state transition.
Also, the states of
the smart contracts,
in most of today's Blockchain
platform is also public.
So, well, confidentiality-preserving
smart contracts
execution essentially here,
everything's encrypted.
So, the data is encrypted and
also the state is
encrypted as well.
The smart contract
essentially and
that's a computation
on encrypted data,
and to perform
the state transition.
Also, at the same time,
we want to ensure that even
though the data in
states are encrypted,
we still want to ensure
that we can have
a proof of correctness
that this state
transition is correct.
>> So, the question is
how we actually enable
this practical way of
doing computation over encrypted
data and in particular,
this confidentiality
preserving execution.
So, this essentially, we
do this by leveraging
a combination of
different techniques
for secure computation.
For insecure computation,
essentially,
we have two main types
of approaches.
The first one is
secure hardware and
the advantage of secure hardware
is that it's
a highly performance.
Its performance is close
to native computation,
and it can support for
general purpose computation.
The challenge for
the other types of approach is
crypto based techniques such as
secure multi-party
computation and
fully homomorphic
encryption, so on.
The challenge for
this type of approach is
that the preference overheads
can be very high.
Oftentimes, its orders of
magnitude higher than
native computation,
and hence, it can only be used
for very limited use cases.
In the Oasis Blockchain platform,
we actually use a combination of
these different techniques
and depending
on the actual use cases
of the smart contracts,
we use a different
combinations of
these techniques to enable
confidentiality
presuming execution.
So now, let me just briefly say
a few words about the secure
hardware aspects.
So, the secure hardware here,
one obstruction is called
just the execution
environments and also
here we call it
the Secure Enclave.
The idea of Secure
Enclave is that,
here we can run a program,
in this case, a smart contracts
inside the Secure Enclave,
and then in this case,
the operating system and
the application that
runs outside of
the Secure Enclave will now be
able to tamper with
what's around the inside,
and also will not be able to
see what's running
inside, and hence,
the Secure Enclave
helps to provide
integrity and confidentiality
of the execution.
Also, at the same time,
the hardware provides
a hardware-based mechanism
for remote attestation
such that the remote to
verify can remotely
verify what has
been run inside
the Secure Enclave
and its initial states.
So, we have developed a research
project called Ekiden,
leveraging approaches
like this and so
we provide security proof
using universal composability,
and that we have
developed a number
of sample applications,
including tiny
machinery models in
healthcare domain and
smart building domain,
and many other applications.
So here, one of
the key capabilities that were
used to enable confidentiality
presuming smart
contract execution
as leveraging the capability
of Secure Enclaves,
and in fact, the Secure Enclaves
can serve as a
cornerstone security
primitive even beyond
the application domain
of Blockchains.
Secure Enclaves can provide
strong security capabilities
and can serve as
a platform for building
new security applications
that couldn't be
built otherwise for
the same practical performance.
Over the years, so
all the hardware
manufacturers have recognized
the importance of building
secure hardware and they all
have built different solutions,
but however, we still have
huge challenges in
building secure hardware.
For example, how secure can it
be under what threat models?
What would you entrust
with the secure hardware?
The ultimate challenge is,
can we actually create
a truly trustworthy
Secure Enclave as a
cornerstone security
primitive that can be
widely deployed and enable
secure systems to
be built on top.
If we can do this,
then we can truly
usher the whole community into
a new secure computation era.
So, what's a path towards
getting trustworthy
Secure Enclave.
So, first we need to have
a open source design.
Open source design provides
transparency that's needed
for the whole community
together to analyze and verify
the security and correctness
of the Secure Enclave,
and that can enable
much higher assurance.
Also, open-source design
helps build a community.
Also ideally, we would like to
provide a formal verification
of the Secure Enclave
and we want to
ensure a secure supply
chain management for
securing the
manufacturing process.
So, towards this goal,
we are doing a project
called the Keystone Enclave,
aiming to build
open-source Secure Enclave
on top of RISC-V,
TEE, which is an open-source
risk architecture
that's available today,
and that we provide
strong memory isolation,
and many other properties.
I would have called to enable
open-source Secure Enclave
that can really be
deployed and be used and
the manufacturers by
any manufacturer and be
used in the real world.
RISC-V actually has been
widely adopted in industry.
The RISC-V Foundation has more
than a 100 members and you
can find out more
information about Keystone
at our website
keystone-enclave.org,
and we have a number of goals
encased in the
projects to help us
to finally achieve the goal
of building an open-source
Secure Enclave.
This is a collaboration
between Berkeley and MIT
and with the other
institutions joining,
and we plan to have
a first release this fall
on both with deployed on FPGA,
as well as, actually on
the demo chip HiFive
Unleashed the RISC-V chip.
So, that's the first
component technology,
confidentiality-preservings
smart contract execution,
and then also, quickly talk
about the second component
technology for
privacy-preserving analytics
and machine learning.
So, while we do data analytics
and machine learning,
there's a lot of privacy risks.
So, for example here,
there are two types of questions,
one is how many trips
were taken in
New York City last year?
And the other one's,
how many trips
did Joe take last week?
So, as you can see you,
one question reflects a trend and
the other one actually leaks
sensitive information
about the individual.
But, to answer
both type of queries,
you actually both need to
actually have access
to data, and hence,
this is an example
showing that just having
access control is
insufficient to be
able to protect privacy and at
the same time being able to
answer queries like this.
There has also been
proposals using
Data Anonymization technologies
to solve this problem,
but that's also insufficient
Data Anonymization can reduce
the utility of data and
also at the same time,
it provides insufficient
privacy protection.
There's a research showing
that anonymized dataset actually,
one is combined with
the other publicly available
datasets can be
used to re-identify
users and hence,
leaking sensitive information
about individuals.
We've also done
the recent work showing
that when you want to train
a deep learning model,
you actually really need
to be very, very careful.
So, the question here is,
do neural networks actually
remember training data?
If yes, can attackers
actually extract secrets in
the training data
from just simply
querying the learned models.
So, in collaboration
with researchers from
Google in our recent paper,
here is an example of one of
the key studies which show
that while we train
a language model on
the email dataset,
in this case, it's
a public Enron dataset.
The Enron email dataset
naturally contains
credit card numbers and
social security numbers
of actual users
and we demonstrated that
attackers can actually
craft attacks to them by
just quering the language model
to be able to extract
the credit card numbers and
social security numbers
from the original
training datasets.
This is an example demonstrating
that even when you are training
a machine learning model,
you have to be really
careful to take
the correct measure to
protect users' privacy.
So luckily, here we actually
have a good solution,
and so we are training
a neural deep learning model,
instead if we change
a differentially privates
deep learning model that,
in this case, both from our
proposed measure, as well as,
an attack evaluation,
we demonstrate
that by tuning
a differentially private
deep learning model,
we can provide much stronger
privacy protection for the users.
>> So, I'm running out of time.
So, I won't have time
to actually go into
the details about
differential privacy.
So, differential privacy
at a high level is
essentially a formal
privacy notion that
helps to measure for
algorithm and the editor
analytics algorithm,
or machine learning
algorithm whether it can
distinguish whether
a particular user's data has
been used in producing
the data analytics results
or tuning the machine
learning model.
So, differential privacy provides
a very strong notion for
protecting user's privacy in
data analytics and
machine learning.
There has been
very limited real-world use
of differential privacy
including Google and Apple
use differential privacy
in very limited setting.
There's no previous
real-world's deployments of
differential privacy for
general-purpose analytics.
There are a number
of challenges for
deploying differential privacy in
practice in the real world
including usability
for non-experts,
broad support for
analytics queries
in machine learning and
also easy integration with
existing data environments.
There's no previous system
that addresses all these issues.
In collaboration
with Uber we have
developed new systems to address
these challenges and in
our system Chorus and Optio,
we essentially develop
techniques and
tools to automatically
rewrite data analytics
and machine learning
pipelines to enforce
differential privacy as well as
other desired privacy
requirements.
Some of our technology has
already been deployed at
Uber for protecting privacy
in their internal data analytics.
So, putting together
confidentiality preserving
smart contract
execution and privacy
preserving data analytics
and machine learning.
So, this enables the privacy
preserving smart contracts.
Now, let me just
briefly talk about
the third component technology
as scalable smart
contract execution.
Again, I don't have
a lot of time left
so let me just go over
this very quickly.
So, typically when people
talk about Blockchain
scalability,
one thing that people
immediately think
about is Blockchain sharding.
It's like you have one lane
of cars but now you
have many lanes in parallel
to improve the throughput
of the traffic.
However, this type of approach
is good for high-throughput of
simple transactions but however,
for the Blockchain applications
that we want to build
these are much more
complex and so the difference
smart contracts can also
depend on each other.
So, to enable scalability
in particular scalability
for complex smart
contract execution,
we have designed and developed
a different Blockchain
architecture
than previous Blockchain
architectures.
In particular by separating
out execution from consensus.
By decoupling the
different functions that
a Blockchain is providing.
So, our design is inspired by
a few key observations
of the limitations and
challenges in today's
Blockchain approaches.
So first, a Blockchain
platform essentially
provides three main
functionalities consensus,
storage and compute.
Our functions in most of
today's Blockchain platforms or
the three functionalities
are coupled
together and hence makes it
really difficult to
scale and also hear
consensus as
the slow operation and
is often the key bottleneck.
When we do sharding,
coordination also is expensive
and can limit
the scalability as well.
So, based on these observations
and to address these challenges
we propose a new
Blockchain architecture
for what we call separating
execution from consensus.
Where we actually decouple
these different functionalities
of a Blockchain platform,
where we separate out
the consensus layer,
the storage layer and
the compute layer.
Where the computer executes
the smart contracts and
the storage layer
persist the state and
the consensus layer agrees
on the state transitions.
So, I think here there's
limited time so I
probably won't have time to
go into the details here.
So, essentially to separate
execution from a consensus we-
so again the compute layer
does the computation and in
this case actually the compute
nodes are stateless so
no consensus protocols
are necessary
and they can optimistically
execute the transactions.
In this case the failures
have no effect on the state,
and the states are persistence to
the storage layer
where the blocks
are persisted and replicated and
again no consensus protocol are
necessary and writes in
this case are idempotent.
Finally, the state transitions
are committed to the consensus
layer and here we use
verifiable computation to
verify the correctness of
the computation and
the consensus layer
essentially tracks
the state transitions
and the transaction ordering.
Then we use different types
of techniques for
verifiable computing
including majority votes,
and a new approach that we
developed and discrepancy
detection and we can also use
other methods such as
zero-knowledge proofs for
verifiable computing.
So, putting all these
technologies together,
we enable privacy preserving
smart contracts as scale.
Here is one of the applications
that we have been building,
together with
other collaborators from
ETH and doctors from Stanford
as well as app developers.
>> An application called Kara,
a privacy-preserving
tokenized data
markets for medical data.
So, medical data is locked in
data silos and the goal of
Kara is to incentivize
doctors and patients
to share data and improve
medical research.
We want to provide an easy, fast,
and secure way for
doctors and patients to
essentially upload
their data to the platform
and share their data and they
can earn rewards for it,
while at the same time,
preserving their privacy.
By utilizing the
privacy-preserving smart contracts
on top of the Oasis Blockchain,
the medical researchers can write
their privacy-preserving
smart contracts
and within the smart contracts,
it can contain code
for training machine
learning models, as well as,
serving machine learning
models and also
the smart contracts can
specify terms of
use, for example,
how users may get
compensated for
contributing their data
to the smart contract.
Also, users and patients,
they can also specify
their own privacy requirements
for their data and
if they agree to
the terms of use of
the smart contract developed
by the medical researchers,
then they can contribute
their data to
the smart contracts developed
by the medical researcher.
Once the smart contract
collects enough data,
then it can train machine
learning models over the data
and then this way can
help medical researchers
and pharmaceutical
companies to do
their medical research and to
help find better cures
for diseases.
With this approach,
it can significantly
reduce the friction for
medical researchers and
pharmaceutical companies to
get access to data to be able
to train machine learning
models for their work.
This is just one of
many examples for
the different use cases that
a Blockchain platform
like this can
enable by providing both
privacy protection,
as well as, scalability.
We just launched
Oasis Labs recently,
we raised $45 million and
we have a lot to build,
we actually also have
launched our private Testnet,
and we're inviting
developers to join
our premier Testnet to build
applications and new technologies
on top of our platform.
So, at Oasis Labs, we're
building privacy-first,
high performance Cloud computing
platform on Blockchain.
New computing paradigm and
computing platform that
has a unique combination
of set-up properties,
privacy protection,
scalability, as well as,
without needing to rely
on any central party.
We hope that this
technology can really
help enable completely
new type of applications
to be built that
couldn't be built today
and for more information
you can go to the website.
Thank you. Questions?
>> Hi, I'm going back to
your original example.
The original example
is there were
two banks and you wanted to
build a machine learning model
that combined
the datasets. Right?
>> Multiple banks.
>> Yeah, multiple banks.
So, my question is can it
come to solve this problem by
just using secure hardware?
What is the Blockchain
connection?
It seems like you're
unioning datasets,
so just encrypt the data,
register keys, and
secure hardware and
maybe run a R program
inside hardware.
>> Right.
>> So, what is
the Blockchain connection?
Are you afraid of someone
tampering the data?
Why do you need Blockchains?
>> So, usually when
you use Blockchain as
that you don't want to rely
on your central party.
So, then you don't need
to say like who is operating
that, so, essentially,
you have a Blockchain platform
that people don't even
need to agree on.
Like who should be
trusted and who should
be operating this?
So, it's just right
a platform that without
relying on any central party
and in particular in this case,
like here I just gave
an example of a few banks,
but you can imagine that in
other scenarios you can have
many parties and you
are now going to
have all of them to agree,
to reach agreements on
like who they want to
trust and who should be
coordinating and running
all these things.
So, with the Blockchain,
it just helps
to again removing the reliance
on any such party.
>> Another question, but
the smart contract code
itself that the
register number object.
That'll still be public that
is not encrypted, right?
>> That's a very
good question, so
in our platform
actually this will
be a choice of the developers.
So, the developer can specify
either they want
their smart contract to be
public or they can
be fully private.
Yeah, in which case,
it will be encrypted.
>> So, there's also this company
Enigma from MIT and I
was reading their white
paper and it seems
like they were also
trying to solve
something very similar,
so maybe if you could say
something comparing
the two approaches
that would be really helpful.
>> I think for privacy-preserving
smart contracts,
in general, people
understand its importance.
Actually, I think it's
a very good problem for
many people to solve and
I think it'll be great
to see the whole community
come together
to overcome
this problem and solve
this problem as
our academic paper is
the first paper in a community
that came out that
actually develop
technology on this,
and again I think it's
a very important problem,
we want to encourage
the whole community
to actually work on this.
>> I had one follow-up question.
So, in one of your earlier slides
you had approaches, right?
You were using secure hardware,
using multiparty
computation, you are
using zero-knowledge proofs
and potentially others.
So, my question is like let's
assume that secured hardware
is really secured.
There I know there
are issues with
that like what do you
need other approaches
because won't it be
able to solve like say
multi-party competition if
you have a secured hardware?
>> Okay, yes that's
a very good question.
So, essentially one
of the main goals of
the Oasis platform with this
privacy-preserving smart
contracts primitive
is that we want
to offer to make it easier for
application developers to use
state of the art security and
privacy technologies without
needing to be a experts,
and also in this case
essentially we provide
a unified secure
computing framework
to leverage a combination
of these different technologies,
and yes, if you're really choose
to fully trust
the secured hardware,
then essentially you
don't need to use the
other and like the crypto
based techniques, but however,
depending on the actual use case
and also depending on
developers preference.
So, some developers they
just want to use
crypto based techniques and if
their application logic
is simple enough
and they don't care
too much about
the performance overheads,
then we are happy to offer
them the choice of not
relying on secure hardware.
>> Any other questions?
Okay, so let's thank
the speaker again.
Thanks, everybody.